- Welcome back everybody.
We've got the legendary
Carol Burnett with us.
Give it up.
(audience cheering)
So let's finish things up here
with something Carol
liked to do on her show
and her comedy specials, which we love,
which is take questions from the audience.
All right, let's turn to our audience
for their questions right now.
So who has a question for Carol?
Oh, everybody has a question for Carol.
All right, well I'm just,
do you, we wanna pick?
Do I wanna pick?
I get to pick, I'm gonna pick
you right here in the blue,
how about that?
(Kelly laughing)
- Hi Carol.
- [Carol] Hi.
- In the 90 years that
you've been on this planet,
what would you say is the
most important thing you've learned?
- Oh, that's a big question.
- Do you have about 40 hours?
(audience laughing)
Not to take yourself too seriously.
- Not to take yourself too
seriously, okay, check.
Okay, I'm gonna go with
orange, back there,
yeah, with the cool red hair, come on now.
- Hi, outside of entertainment,
what do you still want to
accomplish in your life?
- Ooh, outside of entertainment,
what do you want to accomplish?
- George Clooney.
(audience laughing)
- Oh my God.
That's my favorite part
of this whole show.
Oh, anyway.
So who else has a question for Carol?
That was amazing.
Okay, I'm gonna go blue down here.
Blue jacket, okay.
- Carol, this is amazing to be so close
to a legend like you.
I think we're all thrilled,
but could you tell us
where did your famous
Tarzan yell come from?
- Well, I had a beautiful cousin,
we were the same age and around nine,
10 years old, we used to
go to the movies together
and she was beautiful.
I mean, she looked like
a baby Sharon Stone,
I mean, just gorgeous.
- Yeah.
- And so when we would see
a movie with Nelson Eddy
and Jeanette MacDonald, we'd
come home and play them.
And of course, she'd be Jeanette and guess
who would be Nelson.
(audience laughing)
So when we saw Tarzan and Jane,
it was either my being
Tarzan or the monkey.
Or a cheetah, because she was always Jane.
So I taught myself how
to do the Tarzan yell
when I was about nine or 10.
It's a yodel.
- Oh which I love.
- Goes from head to chest,
head to chest, head.
- Yeah.
- I taught that to Beverly
Sills, the opera singer.
- Yes.
- When we did a special
years ago together,
called "Sills and Burnett at the Met."
And Beverly said, "How do
you do that Tarzan thing?"
And I showed it and she did it.
And of course she did it beautifully.
And she said, "You know,
it's a great vocal exercise."
- Yeah, I just love that you
got an opera singer to yodel.
- I know.
- It's like, that's amazing,
I'm like, you never hear that.
- So, okay, well it
has been such an honor.
Thank you guys for the questions.
Those were awesome questions.
- Thank you.
- George Clooney answer, wins the day.
I just have one last thing to say, Jason?
♪ I'm so glad we had this time together ♪
♪ Just to have a laugh or sing a song ♪
♪ Seems we just get started
and before you know it ♪
♪ Comes the time we have to say so long ♪
We got one more verse.
♪ There's a time you
put aside for dreaming ♪
♪ And a time for things you have to do ♪
♪ But the time I like the
best is in the evening ♪
♪ I can spend a moment here with you ♪
(audience cheering)
- You're a doll.
- That was my way of sliding in a duet.
Carol Burnett, everybody.
(audience cheering)
Okay, you can see "Carol Burnett, 90 Years
"of Laughter and Love," tonight on NBC.
You do not wanna miss it, it's amazing.